oh my God oh my God like this [__]
move the [__]
boy
can you imagine
[Music]
welcome to another amazing episode of
careful boys today we have Jesus
[Applause]
one of the dudes in the Discord his name
is brandonian and he wanted to know what
is something that you had to work really
hard to get good at and what is
something that came natural to you
skill you first I like your cholo
glasses by the way thanks they're really
cool thick ass Lokes I have to work
really hard
and amazing and then he has a flannel on
too I know that's what I'm saying dude
only button the top one locals for life
it definitely looks like your nickname
would have been a Chino homie [__]
it's always a Chino in every Mexican
game yeah dude anything that slanted
eyes is
like it was born that way
uh something that I was yeah something
you had to work on and then something
that came natural
it's gonna sound cocky but I think being
funny which one is you have to work so
hard at being funny I do
but then it came natural wait huh I'm
naturally like funny like that's all I
know but then I had to work really hard
to be like uh right to right material
and learn how to be funny oh control
your funny control my funny because if
when you're a person that was funny you
put them on stage they're not going to
get the time nope it's different your
everything's that everything dilutes
because that's the skill yeah it's an
actual yeah learn how to like like uh
each second you have to make it worth it
that's like you can you can learn how to
[__] can you fight so you're like
naturally funny but you have to work on
your comments but I have to work really
hard to be funny on stage uh that's what
it was but I was naturally funny but it
was definitely professional application
definitely not one of those things you
can just be like I'll just go through
the [__] around
you might be hot for a year after that
you gotta work you gotta be something
you're natural at but then something you
have to work hard at well it's two
separate things one thing that you're
natural at I think for me it's pretty
like dance dance was hard for me I I was
all really learn a lot of stuff yeah I
had to work pretty hard at that and how
bad were you though were you like
rhythmless because that's no it wasn't
like Rhythm when I was missing it's just
like the I guess like have just doing it
well
like uh yeah it's like hard to like it
was really hard for me to learn counts
and to learn like uh like the
memorization yeah that's super hard yeah
yeah that's true I didn't I was no way a
natural at that like when someone goes
all right we're gonna go five and six
and uh like it looked like nothing to me
yeah
oh [__] [__] is that that's called
isolation yeah dude [__] do you not
[__] no dude Jesus knows his [__]
guy dude he's a musician not a dancer
who brought the Filipino dude more
natural at music yeah that's something
that comes natural to me I think for
like uh I don't even remember a time
that I couldn't hear music and know what
the notes were whoa I don't even like
that for sure since I was like a kid
who's been like that's a normal thing so
you could hear music and you just know
what all the letters are like CB most of
them yeah no way that's that's when like
you know like if someone goes play this
song and then like listen to it it's
like I I trip out yeah I I trip out when
people do that like I just heard the
song and I played it let me try it what
the [__] that's [__] crazy but that's
that's something that like just that's
how I started is because I would just
listen to it that is mine yeah I would
listen to like other things
you'll be sad it's mad
I'm trying to think about it okay to
smile I want to see a dance move dude
when you go to the club and a girl's
like hell anyway about the [__] did I
hear that guy
the girl just like hey dance hot You
Wanna Dance the [__] out of here no
that's that's true I was kind of like
that for a long time oh [__] oh [__] oh
[__] grumping dude oh [__]
yeah
a lot of dudes were like that at the
time yeah really yeah because I didn't
know how to social dance freaking years
oh that's true yeah you didn't know how
to step in the Name of Love
if you're a social dancing what are you
what are you throwing down dude yeah
with nothing that's the key is you're
trying to grind yeah two steps well yeah
but yeah I mean social oh when they
grind on your freaking I think the idea
of social dance is just to make the
other person feel comfortable this is my
social dance that's social Dancing Yeah
I go like this I'm really good at like
awkward social dancing but uh to work
hard on like the actual stuff like
popping and stuff that I had to practice
a lot oh really yeah but if I'm just
vibing I'm just like I don't care do
they do [__] little circle like
battles anymore is that a thing not it
uh yes it is still a thing it would
depending on who you're not at the
high-end clubs they'll kick you out for
that [__] it's really big I've never
seen it in the Vegas club no not in
clubs where they they're more centered
on bottle service they don't want people
breaking in a circle that's so small is
there like a is there Asian clubs yeah
yeah
I always wanted to see that where two
groups come and then they go head to
head head to head you know yeah while
you're there like in the white chicks
are they dancing you're a robot against
my robot yeah yeah they have all dancers
that happens let's let the secret
weapons that happens at dancer events
that take place in clubs
when it's like it's a regular Club
everyone's just drunk okay yeah yeah
yeah you have a [__] move that is
like a like a finish him [__] oh he
does he does like like this [__] move
the [__] and then he threw him
can you imagine can you that's like
he did it we're finished we just gotta
finish him
he's like oh
oh [__] Ryan's got a bunch all of my
moves were meant to be finishing moves
this guy has some crazy ones that's like
old [__] this one does that big dick
energy over here dude this guy does a
backflip and lands on his head no way
you do that
he lands on his head
yeah that's crazy
on the forehead but yeah that none of
that stuff came natural
oh my God there's a fog dude what are
you [__] mean to do that dude I
immediately in a wheelchair a legit a
finished move [__]
well that's interesting I don't think
anything ever came natural to me I tried
everything and sucked at everything like
what what did you suck at what are you
talking about bike riding skateboarding
order like everything that I got into oh
I just did it yeah and then I'm just are
you surprised that this worked I don't
even hear like oh this works
on YouTube it works no you just get on
right like snowboarding and [__] like
you just get on and you just start
feeling it and then yeah you're just
like man how come I can't do jumps like
that guy right yeah and then like you
just try to jump and you fall on your
ass and you just keep doing it over and
over and then one day you land and you
don't know why you just keep going yeah
dude maybe you're naturally good at
doing it I'm not really good at
impulsively falling and everything I
could I see what you're saying though
I've always been like at I was good at
the beginning levels but I never got to
the next step yeah I think that's like
skating like I got to like I got to
ollie I can kickflip but after that it's
like that's it that's pretty good and
it's like that's it you're good at
trying I mean yeah and then after like I
knew that if I'm gonna get good I'm
gonna have to invest time and it's like
I don't really yeah I'll give it I could
I could enjoy it to ride right like I
know how to ride a bike exactly I know
how to bodyboard like I could ride it I
could do it but then I never got to the
next level of like um have like above
average oh yeah just a rider right yeah
yeah yeah but you don't need to yeah
every hobby that I touched it's always
been oh I like doing this with my
friends or whatever and I don't think
I'm good people might say that you're
good but you like it
you're not really good or maybe that's
why that's a funny way of putting it
yeah yeah well that's why their
standards are low that's why right yeah
like to me a good is your professional
you're like winning competitions or
you're really good but then I don't
think comparing your no you're a casual
Enthusiast I think it's just normal it's
like walking like cooking that you're
good at that yeah you're just casually
you're a hobbyist yeah yeah so well what
is one hobby that you were like that was
weird to you that you did and it was
like this is weird but it's like a hobby
of mine piranha collecting piranha
selling you're collecting piranha I used
to sell there's a wholesale we're on a
seller distributor dude with that
ponytail I can tell you where I saw
piranhas this guy's got iguana yeah it's
kind of exotic something
I dabbled in on a lot of like I I did a
lot of illegal trades oh I could tell
when they knock arms dealer for a little
bit of drugs
just a little bit of everything you know
dude memory became a big Kingpin but see
I dabbled I dabbled in there tried it
out it's enjoyed it yeah now this guy is
a matcha Kingpin now oh yeah right now
dude and that's from arms dealer to
matcha tea and Boba but I bet you
learned a lot about you know selling
stuff through selling piranhas yeah yeah
this is the same they can't [__] you
know do him dirty you know you'll be
like dude I know that trick yeah you
gave me I think selling came natural to
me
oh that's good I've been selling since I
was a kid so like I would um uh
everything that I wanted to share with
others but also I thought it was cool
that you can you can get money in return
you got you like I I told the story
before but I bought a big pack of pogs
and I was like well why would they buy
it from me if the store is selling it
for five bucks each so I'm like I'm
gonna sell it for 450. there you go and
then so of course everyone bought it
because I'm selling it cheaper than the
store they're like how are you getting
it for this Jeep but let me tell you
something my dad found out he beat my
ass so [__] hard he was like you're
losing all this money you're blowing
your allowance that's fun check this out
though I'm [__] killing the market
like yeah but he's like but you're
buying it from the store that you're
trying to compete again
so they're they're not just buying the
product they're buying the person dude
yeah we're selling your personality yeah
yeah I could have another five dollars
I'm gonna go buy some more I really buy
him for that weird guy with a [__]
ponytail
it tells me crazy stories
that's crazy kids would always be
selling candy so we would go yeah that
was fun just finding [__] to sell all
the time yeah yeah did you sell like
Playboys or something did you sell like
little play girls
no I remember I had a hot tape in my
[__] dad's garage see sex was always
for free for us what was on the tape oh
dude I know but what was it you know but
it was like super General oh no dude it
was like one of those like you see it
was mostly the [__] night
it's the guys the guy just looking
mostly the guy
[Laughter]
yeah but it was like at least one titty
it was literally we were watching for
like two seconds and then just when we
get like oh yeah
you're crazy
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah any fighting stuff come natural to
you in my head I was world champion in
my head I was the most talented guy in
the room I was better than everybody but
in reality I was really bad this is my
first started because in my head I
thought I was [__] gonna be so good I
was like oh I'm gonna be like I had all
these dreams of like technically in my
head I was like I'm better but everybody
I wasn't that definitely would you have
fun I thought it was but would you have
fought Ron are you guys the same weight
class we might have actually wow we
might have you both kept on the same
track yeah maybe were you fighting at
school no no like just um because when I
first started uh like After High School
I like joined an MMA gym oh you got into
it yeah but um what was the question
again what was it did it come natural
what came natural and what was what was
something hard it kind of came natural
but I just for me with anything physical
or any skill like I just needed to do it
a bunch of times like yeah I could
understand how to like break things down
but I needed the Reps of doing it over
and over and over again for me to even
have confidence and like to be able to
do it yeah yeah yeah it took me a while
definitely were you obsessed with like
getting it down like you didn't feel
comfortable if you didn't get it done
like I need to figure this out yeah yeah
yeah like I would I think I'm more of a
perfectionist but that kind of stops me
in a lot of ways because I'm like oh
well [__] up if I can't do it right then
I'm not gonna do it like that kind of
stops me a lot uh but it reminded me of
my father yeah yeah yeah no for real
though like because that was my stress
it was like I have to get this perfect
the technique has to be this way if it's
not this way that it's not right but um
I realized that like yeah there's you
know it doesn't really serve you that
much it can but you have to learn how to
to control it but for me it was just all
about reps as far as things that come
natural to me
I think um
it kind of in a weird I think building
relationships with people oh wow
conversation that comes pretty much
great that's interesting I feel like I
could sit down and talk to anybody I
could say that without giving away
anything about who I'm not going to tell
you anything about me
you'll not you will never know Nick but
you can talk to Nick oh yeah oh so what
do you do yeah something going on uh
hold on dude
he's very good at the moving around yeah
I'm just like God I thought about it
[__] dude I got to take this call yeah
oh hold on hold that thought
you know Nick but who is Nick who is
Nick yeah off camera I won't shut the
[__] up dude on camera I'm [__]
silent dude because of these [__]
dicks and your comments and your
bullying
so you used to fight though yeah a
little bit no way what was your the most
satisfying thing when you like fighting
like what's one of the things that
you're like this is very satisfying
knocking someone out not even man no it
doesn't feel good nah he doesn't like
hurting people what yeah some of the
best fighters I'm saying this least
violent dude that's what I heard but
like I don't make sense to me yeah I
remember I knock one kid out and it was
satisfying like it was if it is personal
if it's somebody you don't like I think
the younger I was the more I like when I
was younger when I would hurt somebody
I'd be like hell yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
hell yeah but as I got older and as I
started experiencing my own injuries and
like how that kind of [__] with me and
then doing that to like people that like
what's that perspective on that I was
like I don't know if I could do this
anymore yeah I don't want to hurt give
someone and you don't hate the other app
no like you guys are going in as a
competitive sport like and also too like
in the training room you have to beat up
your friends all the time yeah you're
beating the [__] out of each other yeah
like especially when we're like
kickboxing we would try to kick the [__]
out of each other and it just like after
a while for me I just don't think I had
the heart for it I really don't think I
did I don't think I had the aggression
for it and I think that chip on my
shoulder that I got me into that sport
was gone by like the third year I did it
that makes sense and I was like in a way
I don't want to say I was like lying to
myself but I kind of was lying to myself
about like trying to be a fighter like I
just wasn't really like I was like I
don't know if this is for me because you
know how it feels you should have been
single
you would have had a bigger chip on your
shoulder there's no one to sucked the
pain out of you that's true that's true
that's true if I was like by myself but
even Danny like it was it was just like
a weird I still can't believe it seems
like such a long time ago like I when
people were like oh you're a fighter I
was like nah I barely was a fighter like
I dabbled and dabbled into it I
definitely dabbled in it but it wasn't
like I don't think it was for me
that's what I am with spanking I don't
know if I can spank my kids because I
know how that felt you know yeah I felt
I think I could do it you know they
could do it yeah I don't think I could
do it I think they're gonna make it I
might dabble yeah
what's something for you Bart either one
of those
um I think the theme that came hard was
uh Fitness oh because I started like
when I was a freshman I didn't even
break 100 pounds yet
when I was sophomore I finally broke 100
pounds like 105 pounds and then so I
started lifting and it took me like a
whole year to get from like 105 to like
130 pounds what grade uh so I was by the
time I was a junior I was like 130
finally wow that's Lifting for a year
you know what Junior High School a
junior in yeah Junior High School
yeah dude I was I was 130 in high school
yeah
freshman I was 90. oh you were 90 and
then I went to like 105 110. that's a
lot oh so you had to work to get to I
had to work yeah okay yeah cause I just
do a [__]
dude yeah I was like I'm like hey guys
it's not that hard dude you're a [__]
hamburger guy
but but I did I get it though and I want
to and then I worked to 1 30. oh and
then by the time when I was a senior and
I was like 160 165 and then I remember
so I was in uh I was in wrestling and in
wrestling it's very weight oriented
right because yeah yeah and I remember a
freshman would just come on and was like
220 and I'm like they just make people
different you know or like because when
I was a freshman I was a like 90 this
guy literally is two of me and one of
the same species at the same age what
that's crazy and it's like I kept
training and kept working out and then I
went to boot camp and when I came back
out I was immediately back to 1 30 again
so I had to work my way back up so like
we we just had a bodybuilder on but uh I
would say I was one of those guys where
they're like you're genetically not
inclined to put on like muscle that fast
I don't think I got that Gene dude I got
a big boy Jane dude so I would say
that's yeah that [__] growing
the easy theme that came I think was
math I know it's very stereotypical
[Laughter]
you just get numbers like not like
basically oh it's like 35 I was about to
hit you with a number or nothing
complex problem that I have to solve
I'll [__] crush it wow really dude
like algebra algebra 2 calculus like any
of those or even physics type problems
like I was just very good at like seeing
unknown variables and then like
almost being able to just solve it like
I just I just understood like what the
path that's so impressive I'm like you
know people see a maze and then some
people have to go like another try and
go back yeah and like okay that wasn't
that one for some reason I can see like
a problem or a situation or even like
word problems and [__] or like even like
on standardized tests like sat whatever
I would just read it and I'm like oh
okay I know what the answer is
super impressive that's not me that
ain't me yeah
foreign
thank you